Mental Vlog depuis la maison...
Mais attention, demain ça reprend dans l'autre bureau.
Salut, comme le laissait entendre le titre "p*te à clics" d'aujourd'hui, je vais vous
apprendre à retenir les pays sur une carte de géographie.
C'est donc une vidéo plus orientée mémoire aujourd'hui,
j'essaie vraiment de tout alterner en ce moment,
je reprends un petit peu ça quand même.
Et le but de cette vidéo est double,
c'est déjà de pouvoir retenir des pays de tête,
c'est-à-dire que si l'on vous donne une carte vierge,
vous êtes capables de réécrire les pays,
mais aussi, de mémoire, de pouvoir dire
quel pays est frontalier avec quel pays.
De pouvoir mieux situer sa cartographie, et donc sa géographie.
Alors, quelle méthode aujourd’hui s'offre à nous, quand on veut essayer d'apprendre ça ?
Et bien aucune. La seule méthode, c'est d'apprendre,
d'imaginer à peu près dans sa tête, d'essayer de retenir,
mais il n'y a pas de vraie méthode, que nous apprendraient
les professeurs, pour apprendre ça.
Je n'ai pas une recette tout faite, qui va permettre de faire :
"POUAH" le gros miracle du siècle, mais au moins, une méthodologie pour le faire.
On va prendre pour exemple une carte que l'on connait bien,
et au moins, même si vous n’êtes pas à l'école,
et que ça vous sert pas à l'école, ça vous sert dans votre culture générale.
On va prendre l'Europe, la carte de l'Europe.
Carte de l'Europe ici, en temps normal, sauf si je la mets pas au montage, et là ça serait ridicule.
Alors je la mettrait.
Si vous regardez l'Italie, ça fait une botte, c'est quelque chose qu'on sait depuis toujours, la botte représente l'Italie.
C'est la première pierre de notre édifice, tout va partir là dessus.
Ne prenez pas peur, c'est simple à faire.
Le secret c'est de trouver deux ou trois images, qui nous viennent par pays.
Alors ça peut être avec la forme des frontières, la forme du pays, mais aussi autre chose, on va y revenir.
Regardez l'Autriche, par exemple: l'Autriche, moi, ça me rappelle un petit peu une autruche,
une autruche qui serait plus ou moins allongée, en tout cas on ne verrait pas les pattes,
avec son long cou qui part en direction de la Suisse.
Et "Autriche" et "autruche", ça se ressemble.
Donc "autruche" avec "Autriche"
Ne notez rien pour l'instant, je vais vous expliquer ensuite comment on va faire.
*en riant* J'ai l'impression d'être un prof c'est terrible !
La Croatie, pour moi, ça me fait penser un petit peu à une tête de dinosaure,
avec la gueule ouverte, dont l’œil serait Zagreb.
Ou aussi une pince à linge..
Mais comme j'ai commencé à vous l'expliquer, les images générées peuvent être indirectes.
Notez tout ce que ce pays vous évoque.
La République Tchèque, ça m'évoque rien par ses frontières,
par contre "République Tchèque", ça me fait penser à un "chèque", un chèque bancaire.
Ça me fait aussi penser à un "check", "Check mon pote!"
Pour la Suisse, on dit souvent en plaisantant que la Suisse c'est le pays des médicaments.
Et bien la Suisse, si je pense un peu au médicaments etc, ça me fait penser à un virus.
Je trouve qu'elle a la forme d'une grosse bactérie sur pattes, d'un virus un peu bizarre.
Tout est valable à partir du moment où ça a vraiment un sens un peu précis pour vous.
Par exemple, la Pologne.
La Pologne, quand je la regardais, ça me disait rien de particulier.
Mais "Pologne" ça me fait penser à "polo".
Mais "polo" ça me fait penser à la chanson "Paulo" de Stromae.
"stʁomaj" pour les puristes.
Donc la Pologne me fait penser à lui.
Maintenant, ce que vous pouvez faire, sur une carte de l'Europe ou sur une carte que vous essayez d'apprendre,
c'est d'imprimer la carte vierge, sans pays à l’intérieur,
juste le nom du pays de noté à la limite.
Et vous notez, pour chaque pays, ce que ça vous évoque comme image, directement dans le pays.
Ce que ça vous évoque de manière naturelle, pour vous.
Pour certains, c'est sûr, il faudra se creuser un petit peu la tête.
Même à une époque où je donnais des formations sur la mémoire,
il n'y a jamais personne qui a complètement séché.
Même si vous croyez ne pas pouvoir trouver quelque chose,
En vrai vous pouvez, faîtes vous confiance.
Même les chemins les plus tortueux sont possibles, et sont logiques.
Regardez ce que j'ai fait avec la Pologne !
Viens ensuite la phase où vous allez commencer à associer les pays entre eux,
par rapport aux possibilités, encore une fois.
Et là, si on regarde l'Europe, j'ai spontanément une histoire.
Mais vraiment, en plus, elle me revient, je n'ai même pas besoin de regarder des notes ou quoi que ce soit.
L'autruche est en train de manger un gros virus.
Bon, elle est allongée elle mange un gros virus.
Et elle est elle même assise dans un nid.
Donc l'autruche c'est l'Autriche, le virus c'est la Suisse.
Donc je sais qu'au bout de l'Autriche il y a la Suisse.
Et je sais que l'autruche est placée au dessus d'un nid.
Et le nid, je sais que c'est la Slovénie.
Mais en vrai, dans mon imaginaire, ce qu'elle prend pour un nid est l'espèce de touffe de cheveux blonde
d'un énorme crotale, la gueule ouverte, crotale pour Croatie.
Et en guise de plumage, vous savez au niveau des fesses de l'autruche, il y a toujours des grandes plumes.
En guise de plumage, du haut vers le bas, il y a une gros chèque,
ce chèque il n'est pas pour n'importe qui, il est pour Paulo qui est juste au dessus.
Paulo pour la Pologne et chèque pour la République Tchèque.
Paulo qui va se servir du chèque pour aller dans un slow.
Avec un femme grise qui a des ongles très longs.
Et la femme grise avec les ongles longs, pour moi, "ongles" c'est Hongrie
Je pense que vous comprenez la mécanique,
il faut que vous trouviez la votre, avec comme ça des paquets de pays.
Suivant la carte que vous devez apprendre vous reliez ça ensemble.
Essayez de créer des scènes, des images comme ça qui s'associent,
exactement comme je viens de vous faire dans la démonstration.
Voyez ce que vous pouvez relier ensemble.
Il se peut qu'à la fin, il y ait quelques pays sur la carte que vous devez apprendre, que vous n'avez pas pu relier.
Des espèce de "no man's land" qui restent un petit peu seuls.
Vous pouvez, soit essayer de les apprendre par cœur d'une manière plus classique,
soit de prendre le temps encore une fois de trouver une image correspondante,
qui fait que vous savez que les trois que vous arrivez pas à placer, au final, dans l'ordre c'est "pif, paf et paf".
C'est une méthode qui fonctionne très bien.
Encore une fois, je sais que certains d'entre vous vont se dire:
"Non mais ça c'est encore plus compliqué que de la faire, autant le faire normalement."
Vous avez le droit de penser ça, il n'y a pas de problème.
Maintenant, moi ce que je vous dit, c'est que ça, ça marche.
Moi ça a toujours marché pour moi, ça a marché pour ceux à qui je l'ai appris et qui ont essayé de le refaire.
Donc si vous galérez à apprendre vos cartes en géographie,
prenez le temps d'essayer de faire ça, c'est plus long à l’apprentissage.
Du moins ça semble plus long mais en vrai c'est pas plus long au final.
Et ça tient beaucoup mieux.
Vous aurez pas besoin de réviser, moi dans mes images c'est très clair,
quand je pense à l’autruche, je vois tout de suite les frontières de l’Autriche.
Je vois ce que ça donne.
C'est pas quelque chose qui peut s'apprendre autrement, la forme des frontières.
Et quand je pense à l'autruche je vois tout de suite la Suisse, je vois le nid,  je vois le crotale,
je vois le chèque, je vois Paulo.
Ça se compose instantanément.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu, mais en encore plus j'espère qu'elle vous servira.
Si c'est le cas c'est super, et n'oubliez pas ...
Il faut que je me déplace pour ça !
... de vous abonner à la chaîne si c'est pas déjà fait.
Le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant 1an,
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre, et demain j'ai une invitée sur la chaîne !
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17h. Tchao !